okay another way to handle the receding
area is where you've got a a cleared off
area and what we've done here is removed
the existing vegetation with a
non-selective herbicide and we've got it
down to the bare soil now and so the
goal is to just disturb the soil
slightly to give the seed something to
mix with and then mix the C with that
soil and then firm it back down now
there's lots of ways to do this the way
to do it on a larger scale is with a
manthis or kind of a small scale
rototiller here that we can start up and
run and scratch up the surface and then
rake the soil to get a nice grade and
another way to do it is just with a hand
rake iron rake to just stir it up for
smaller areas so here we go we're going
to start this baby up here
we're just gonna try to get some of this
debris off of here rocks and mushrooms
and leaves just try to get a nice gray
to it again taking off some debris you
want to remove the bigger rocks grass
can't grow on the rocks like that
my trinket from a couple different
angles just to get a little grade on it
okay so now we've got it disturb this is
an area where we'll be choosing a shade
tolerant seed because of the trees we
have here we have a right shade is the
predominant factor that's going to limit
the grant growth of the grass so we've
selected a shady seed mix here and I'm
just going to take it as a handful right
in my hand and I'm just going to
distribute it evenly over the surface by
hand nice and easy keep an eye on just
trying to get it uniform shake in motion
like you're feeding chickens can't wait
to see that on the website and that's a
relatively uniform amount of seed that
you'll want to get on there and again
you see the street on the surface we
want to mix it into about sixteenth to
an eighth of an inch so I'll just come
back with the back of the rake here and
we'll just rake it through in one in a
couple of different directions and you
can see how quickly see it gets mixed in
there
and then once we get all that seed mixed
in there there's a couple of ways to do
this with a wheel of a wheel barrel
wheel on your tractor just to come in
and firm that seed bed down to get that
seed in contact with the soil fairly
easy to do with your feet in a small
area works pretty good okay now she's
all firm down and we'll get our mulch
just spread out uniformly mulch is gonna
be critically important particularly if
you're you know going to rely on Mother
Nature to provide the water if you're
going to be doing the watering yourself
it is not always necessary to use mulch
but in this case it's a good idea and
that's about the uniformity so that when
you look down you can see you know
thirty percent of the ground through the
straw